Kim Jong-un just called for nuclear
attack Readiness against the U.S and
South Korea Kim Jong-un ordered a drill
to launch a nuclear counter-attack which
included launching a tactical missile
with a mock nuclear warhead That Way
North Korea is prepared to retaliate
when America and South Korea inevitably
decide to annihilate the hermit Kingdom
he also recently ordered the military to
start preparing for all-out war after
the U.S in South Korea conducted an air
drill with bombers apparently 1.4
million North Koreans also decided to
re-enlist in the North Korean military
to prepare for war but let's be real
volunteering probably has a different
meaning in North Korea